all right and we are live I love podcast
Lord Cognito here floydsgaming.net and
who is this fine gentleman we have in
the realm of Xbox today
what's up everybody I'm Chris osaki
creative director for Forza Motorsport
awesome Forza Motorsport this is the big
one this is a turn tens baby the
simulation dream for a lot of people and
I just want you to talk about the game
for again for people who are unfamiliar
you're releasing a new title tell us
about Forza Motorsports for those who
are unforbidden to the whole race exceed
yeah absolutely so Forza Motorsport if
you're familiar with Forza at all I
think a lot of people understand uh what
Forza Horizon is that's pretty popular
you're the Forza Horizon guy right I'm
the Casual
um whereas on the Forza Horizon side
that game is really about exploration
and uh Beauty and and that sort of of
road trip if you will right whereas
Motorsport is all about skill it's all
about competition it's about getting on
tracks and and proving who's the fastest
um and it's just getting into a deep
simulation both from the physics side of
things vehicle Dynamics as well as a
deep World simulation where you've got
time of day changing you got weather
resistance
now and so all of that world simulation
is is all about finding the last bit of
time in every car on every track awesome
awesome and I think what assimilation
guys appreciate is is that attention to
detail with physics and um you know one
thing I want to ask you as far as like
the changes that you made from past
iterations of Forza to now in
relationship to physics and realism and
also AI if possible yeah uh the first
thing we did a long time ago uh was look
at our physics model all up like what we
need to do to have the absolute best
driving model that we could such that we
could have the best players in the world
find incredible amounts of depth of
Gameplay at the limit right making sure
that there was just amazing gameplay all
the time for everyone
so the first thing that we had to do is
was redo our tire model completely so
the I think for Sim fans
um it's where the rubber meets the road
forget that right
um it it is the most important part for
depth of gameplays to make sure your
tire model is is Bar None right so we
went from a single point of contact back
in the fm7 time frame to eight points of
contact now so the contact patches is is
more Faithfully rendered and understood
and then we've also increased the
physics model on our tires model Tire
models uh entire model by six times
um so it's High Fidelity high frequency
and you have a really really good
contact patch this time around what this
means is just from a tire contact patch
um it's hyper realistic and it's just
the grip levels feel realistic it's just
super authentic and um and really robust
that's pretty awesome the fact that you
felt the need to to kind of write that
to kind of improve the physics and get
more of a realism will that help people
who are also like non-controller and and
who just wouldn't use like steering
wheel guys will that help them as well
oh more so than anyone else so I think
what has been great about Forza is we've
had some of the best steering
implementation on or driving
implementation on a controller or
Gamepad um I think the controller feels
always been great both on Horizon and
Motorsport
um where we have found additional gains
in terms of gameplay and feel is with
the wheel with these new tire changes so
it feels even better on the on the
control than it ever has before but the
wheel has the ability to really pull out
the last bits of Fidelity in the tire
model and all the suspension modeling
to really understand the car Dynamics a
lot more at this time around
pretty awesome another thing I noticed
um you know as far as AI like you guys
to me are like the innovators in terms
of like
drivatar and and you know having this
kind of like you know AI as far as car
behavior and things that nature what
changes can we talk about there that has
happened as far as the single player
aspect of force upon a sport yeah so
first and people probably heard me say
this before about AI we've completely
rebuilt the AI
um and they are now as fast as our
fastest human drivers without any cheats
without any hacks without any rubber
banding so I think a lot of players in
the past would be seeing a car that's of
equal power or weight or what that what
sort of thing and they'll just see them
pull them on a straight and you're like
why they out
yeah and that's because we artificially
added either things like horsepower or
grip in the past to make them
competitive because they couldn't drive
at the level of our fastest players what
we've done and actually not because we
wanted our AI to do this we actually
sought out to make the most skill based
system around car progression around you
know unlocking your fastest self and we
went to this whole notion of ten tenths
um that's a that's a notion in
competition driving that you know when
you're driving at 10 tenths you there's
nothing left in the car you're driving
you're using every bit of power and grip
to get around the fastest you can so if
you're driving a nine tenths you're
really really close but you still have
some more time to get so we wanted to
see if we could build a system that that
was like hey we know if you're driving
at 10 10s or nine tenths or five tenths
or what have you
every second of the track right and if
we could build that that would allow you
as a player to figure out oh I'm
actually a little bit slower than I
thought I was I actually have a lot of
time left in this corner I scored a 5.6
out of 10. when in these other Corners
I'm scoring you know nines or or nine
point fives I'm really close to the
Limit there I got to work on this one
corner I don't know why but I got to
work on it we're like how do you build
that system and how do you build a
system that that allows you to do that
for over 500 cars with hundreds and
hundreds of upgrades and different ways
to tune it
so the way we actually solve that is we
built a system of AI that would be able
to drive as fast as possible with all of
those different combinations and that's
how we got our AI to be that fast is
because we needed a system that allowed
players to understand how how much of
the car they were using
um so it's kind of funny how we backed
into the better AI via like that that
whole thing yeah you know that's
actually pretty awesome I think the
thing that I noticed off the off the
back was that how you talking about
almost like the progression it's like a
change in a sense that it's almost like
an RPG now it's like you know I'm the
guy that I'm really terrible at like
simulation and that the Focus right of
each turn each segment but it almost
felt like the game was broke down in a
way where it's like okay you've improved
on this segment here this was your best
like the track was almost broken up into
little parts and then I could use that
as motivators to learn it and get better
so I guess the question in relation back
to a is with that system do you have
things in place because I heard you have
things in place kind of like a a driver
let's say for example the way he behaves
as well as from a simulation standpoint
you know guys like me that might be a
little aggressive and rub paint like how
do you factor are those two separated as
far as far as the behavior of of how
everyone's ranked in of drivers yeah so
there's
you touch on a number of things that I
that I think are really really
interesting for people I I think the
first thing is that our AI
um we built our AI to be clean and safe
right so when you're racing against the
game and our AI or driver Towers
they will try to get out of your way
they'll they'll try to make sure oh
they're you're on the racing line I'm
not I'm gonna try to like avoid trying
to turn into you I'm sure you know it
they're giving you space which allows
you to really start dialing in your
speed right finding how to break how to
how to take those Corners
um rather than really be aggressive and
challenge you like it's not a it's not a
game about crashing so much as it is
about finding your fastest self like
really finding that skill so we've
dialed in the AI to be more about that
to help you as a player really find
um all the time and really enjoy just
driving the game
um
the other side of it is we we have
things for multiplayer if you jump into
that side of things we have things where
it's a driver rating and a safety rating
that helps you be Match Made against
players that are as safe or as unsafe so
almost like a safety rating and like
almost like an ELO of driver skills okay
that's exactly what it is
um So the faster drivers will have a
faster or a higher driver rating
um so it's like your ELO rating uh
so yeah the safety rating is more just
about hey are you are you a dirty driver
are you hunting people off the track are
you cutting the track all the time well
you'll be Match Made eventually against
only drivers like that because I've been
put my little pool which is yeah so so
the cleaner faster drivers we put
together and this even the slower safe
drivers will also be put together with
with all of the safety is most important
in our game guys right
um and so if you are unsportsmanlike if
you're a dirty driver you'll be mostly
match made with those types of drivers
yeah yeah no that's awesome I love that
just did the segmentation and again to
preserve the clean racing and stuff like
that which falls it should be more
associated with it's kind of what I was
going to ask is like first let's talk
about the graphics of the game like I
thought the game looked really
impressive me and King were playing it
blown away you know I want to talk about
we were playing actually on Xbox series
X Hardware right so I want to talk about
the the modes because I think it was
like three different modes that you guys
had set and then also because of all the
different configurations all the people
all the different configurations that
will play together so let's talk about
the console first
yeah so on the series X we have three
different render modes and we've found
that you know we we defaulted people to
the performance mode which is 4K 60 uh
and it's what you guys played today
um or I actually don't know if that's
what you can see yeah I've played like
it was like a variant I believe like it
was like a a little bit of Ray tracing
but like oh I see yeah we have
performance RT yes right before it's our
team yeah so that that turns on Ray
tracing on the track as well so that
you'll be running at 60 but you're also
uh you also have different Ray tracing
abilities our our capabilities so it's
it's more of a visual mode but you still
want 60 frames a second right
um versus 4K 60 the performance mode is
more about making sure your your frame
rate is at 60 and your resolution is as
high as can be
um and and so you know we're trying to
allow players to to make their own
decision about how they want to play do
they want to favor you know resolution
or do they want to favor additional
visual options uh and really it's a
personal preference
um I I think it looks incredible either
way uh I just love the option to make
sure that you can dial that in with 60
if you really want frame rate you really
want resolution you want different types
of graphical opportunities that's all
dialed in in both type in both consoles
you can dial that in how you so both
Series S as well yeah you're going to
have some options there as well so we'll
unveil all the different rendering modes
as well as options
um as as we move forward okay just good
question because there was a third
option I thought on the series X which
was almost like a ray tracing mode only
maybe 30 frames per second that kind of
thing so you have that and we'll do we
know or will it be revealed later as far
as serious yeah we'll talk it's fairly
complex in terms of all the
um all the different options that are
turned on or or not being used in all
the different modes we'll have a full
rundown of that pretty shortly sounds
good sound good someone talk about the
online portion the racing the
competitive aspect you know you talked
about the AI aspect so I just wanted to
say like what we play seem to be almost
like a starter cup Build You Up Get You
kind of a couple of qualifying races get
you into it and then throw you in which
I thought was really cool for
acclimation so how are we handling the
online portion of the game so people
want to be into competitive racing yeah
so there's multiple
variations or experiences within our
online mode our major mode the mode that
we've never had before we call in
featured multiplayer now we put most of
our weight behind developing that
experience because we believe this is
going to be the best way that people are
going to experience online competition
um so we talked a little bit about the
driver and safety rating that's going to
be a big portion of that side of things
so in feature multiplayer you'll be
match made with your safety rating with
your driver rating that's the first
thing the second thing is that in
featured multiplayer it's broken into
two major areas the spec racing side of
things and the open racing side of
things so in the spec racing side of
things you have
very very balanced and tuned cars that
that are very competitive against each
other so no matter what car you choose
you're pretty much going to be in that
ballpark competitively okay
uh and on the Open Class side of things
or the open series uh it's more just
about ability to a specific kind of
range of of of Pi that's what we call it
or power in the game and you can bring
whatever you want so it's a little less
balanced it's a little more open player
Freedom creation that sort of thing on
that side of the site of of a future
multiplayer and on spec racing it's very
very balanced and hypertuned
um and as you mentioned one of the major
things that happened on the on the
featured multiplayer side of things to
intro you to it we actually have a
series called the intro series or the
qualifier series which I think is a
series of three or more races that kind
of establish both your driver and safety
rating but get you used to all the new
uh the new flow of qualifying and you
know open practice and qualifying and
race
um as well as sort of the the penalty
system or our Forza racing regulation
system that is also available in
Builders code you need to get used to
all these systems to really be
successful in multiplayer awesome no I
think that's really cool um I did notice
when I was driving it what a again I was
trying my best to drive clean I really
was right and what would happen is every
once in a while you know you you build
rubber little paint and then I wouldn't
notice an indicator come up kind of say
Collision yeah and it was almost like
the game was judging whether or not it
was legitimate In the Heat of the battle
or was Cognito a little too aggressive
and for the most part it was like you
know nope fine no penalty I think there
was one lap I played well I knew I
literally rammed into somebody it was
something I didn't follow the racing
line I was a little too much and then it
gave me a penalty so is that another
separate system on top of what we talked
about or that's part of the whole thing
regulation system
so in single player in the builders cup
you can actually turn that down just to
track cutting and so you can Collide all
you want if you want to be crashy in our
game you can do that all you like you
wanna you wanna be a horizon player
that's cool that's cool
um no but for real like it it is meant
to be able to tune or dial into the the
level of penalty system that you
actually want so if you want to have a
complete safe clean type of race you can
you can push it all the way to the the
kind of simulation setting or you can
have it more relaxed and not really
worry about collisions but if you want
to actually start dialing that in you
get a little bit more credit payout but
also
you start getting used to the Penalty
system right and it'll potentially get
you ready for multiplayer as well
because you're like oh I kind of
understand what's Happening Here I I can
I I have better racecraft now that I'm
paying attention to the other cars
um now one of the things that you
mentioned was really interesting
um you're like oh is it judging me like
what yeah because it was it was it felt
like a like a tennis match oh no I'm
just interested to see the wait for a
second and then a decision on these
individual things for somebody truth
because what's happening as soon as you
make a collision it freeze frames and
thinks about the 15 seconds or so
leading up to that collision and the 15
seconds or so after that collision and
why is that is because there may be
someone that hits you and then you
because you started spinning out hit
someone else and cause an accident yeah
and that was it was someone else's fault
but that's the point is that you're like
dude that wasn't me right so the game
now is thinking and and looking back at
the history and going oh yeah that
wasn't that wasn't your fault and so
that's a lot of it what's going on there
when it's when it's thinking and judging
you it's actually trying to see and be
as Fair as possible to like really
understand how did you get to this point
in time it wasn't your fault or what did
someone else Ram you and that's caused
the incident yeah that's awesome now is
that also in online yes wow that is the
major system online so we really believe
that this is going to be a real
important thing a differentiator for
something that's really valuable for
online play to ensure that players you
know they're like yeah it's clean racing
but I'm getting penalties all the time
for no reason but this system really
tries to solve a lot of that that is
pretty awesome I want to get to the
actual namesake right it seems that you
didn't put a number this year right this
number so obviously we spoke to Dan and
yourself earlier so the question is you
know what's the mindset by just saying
Motorsport is it like games as a service
that are we looking to add more things
to it like what's the vision this year
this time around Yeah couple things
absolutely right from the start what we
envisioned for this new Forza Motorsport
was that it would be the most part for
this generation and minimum right that
we have no plans for a sequel and that
this was going to be the platform for us
for years and years and years to come
and we would evolved with the community
that we would be a live evolving thing
second by second hour by hour day by day
week by week and that we would be
releasing cars and tracks and features
and quality life fixes and that sort of
thing all the time
um and this was something that we
learned from the previous game like we
want to be agile we want to be of all
the community much quicker than we could
before so one of the biggest things that
we had to do and is actually signify by
dropping the number is that the engine
that supports all this was completely
Rewritten to allow us to be that agile
so so that's the first thing
um the second thing is and this is
something we talked about in our intro
today
The Meta experience like the the heart
of the game we've gone from one through
seven unfortunately one through seven
was really about car collection as the
way to fall in love with cars and this
time around we've moved away from car
collection that's all well and good we
love it but what we want to do for this
new platform is carp progression yeah
yeah so it's all about falling in love
with cars through car progression
through this whole new built not bot
system it's about leveling up cars it's
about building that deeper relationship
with them it's not about collecting all
500 of our cars it's about having a
deeper relationship with a smaller
number love that answer because that's
literally how I felt and I I'm the guy
that usually is guilty of the collecting
aspect in Horizon but what I will say I
almost caught like a car RPG aspect you
know again each time I did something
there was XP there was progression then
it's like you leveled up so it kept
incentivizing me and to your point and
then you form that kind of relationship
right to what the vision of Motorsport
is and I really appreciate that I think
the thing that I first of all this is
very impressive what you guys are trying
to do and just rewriting it the question
I have is and now in reference again all
these different configurations of you
know PC you have the windows we have
steam we have series X Series S so I
guess like how will you manifesting
dealing with all of that because that's
going to be huge playable right and then
from a competitor for the PC guys you
know I know one of the things a lot of
people talk about is kind of like the
frame rate PC guys want to go all the
way you know but sometimes when they do
that no disrespect PC Community
um you know it puts them at a
competitive advantage over console so
how are you balancing that to so that
everyone's kind of Level Playing Field
yeah I I agree I think we're going to
have the most players that we've ever
had in Motorsport This Time Around by
far and away and we saw incredible
numbers in fm7 when we put it on Game
Pass I mean Game Pass is a big change
for us right forgot about Game Pass yeah
so um so yeah shout out to Game Pass
um so yeah we're gonna invite steam
players into this for the first time as
well and so our player pool is gonna be
millions and millions and millions more
players than we've ever had
and one of the biggest things is because
we're we're trying to go after skill and
competition yes I understand PC players
are trying to have the highest frame
rate possible
in single player it's unlocked you can
you can have whatever person a good
single play go all the way absolutely
what we want to ensure is in our
incredibly balanced multiplayer
experience that when you're on PC when
you're on a series X when you're in
series s whether whether you're on a low
end PC or a high-end PC we want to
ensure equal competitiveness across the
board and so that's why we've made some
of the decision that we have there no it
makes sense and I totally get it I guess
the thing for me now as far as um we
talked about the the competitive aspect
we have to talk about some of the things
that are not here right so one of the
things is a little broken heart no no
spectator mode you know is that
something that will eventually come and
then obviously split screen you guys
talked about not not being there for uh
Series S so again all these decisions
that are final as far as Essa split
screen and spectator mode you know is
that final all these things that maybe
could come down the road yeah I think
there's a couple things there one the
most important part is that none of
these features that you're discussing
were part of our initial Vision like
they didn't really map to anything that
we were going to be delivering whether
it was featured multiplayer or the the
builders cup side of things now one of
the most important things that I will
say is we have zero plans for new
features after day one after we're out
there what we what I mean by that is we
haven't planned anything we're going to
be releasing the game with you know with
our full vision intact about what we
want this new Forza Motorsport to be and
then we're going to open the floodgates
everyone's going to be rushing in and
they're going to tell us what they need
what they want so from day one we'll be
listening to the community and
understanding where we believe the
community is going and what they need
and we'll be looking at then supporting
those features they may be those
features that you discussed they may be
other features and it's really about
making sure that our player base is
continually happy and fed and making
sure that they're that we are building
the right game with them sounds good
this is pretty much an undertaking a
labor of love we can tell you know that
the passion for cars to share volume at
launch should be about over what 500
almost you know obviously you know the
graphic guys like myself and King really
appreciate how great the game looked it
drive it felt you know last thing I'd
say you know as far as um what is the
thing you're most excited about as we
start to roll towards launch and what
people are going to get their hands on
this game
well number one the cars just feel
amazing to drive like I really do feel
this that there's there's night and day
between this and what we've ever had
before so I just love driving in the
game so much and I I know people will
enjoy that so every car every car has
Nuance every car has individuality so
all those 500 plus cars they all feel
very very different and um so I think
that's the most important thing but you
know we talked a little bit earlier
about this whole falling in love with
cars thing and that car progression and
um it's the thing that I'm just very
excited that we were able to bring this
time around the the passion that I have
and the relations that I have with my
own Cars and Cars in general
um that feeling what I've experienced
with cars and the community and friends
that I've built around that I wanted to
make sure and the team wanted to make
sure that that came through this time
around and was really the Beating Heart
of this game that's awesome this is
great to hear again Lord cogadito the
Casual racing guy with his perspective
but I will say you know I was very
impressed I thought the game played well
it felt it looked good you know
appreciate the quick upgrade button for
guys like me who don't want to go
through a thousand settings and stuff
like that that was there and I really
think you guys got something special in
your hand and we're looking forward and
pulling for you guys towards the launch
an absolute pleasure the Lords of turn
10 in the realm of ILO podcast thank you
so much
Cheers Cheers